The Joe Rogan Experience but again that
goes back to like you have an excuse all
the time to do the wrong thing you have
an excuse all the time to go back to the
familiar you have an excuse all the time
why to say the whole world is against
you and be right
but so what now what now what are you
gonna do about it how happy do you want
to be your life will rise to the level
you settle for and just to keep pushing
what did you do how did you get out of
it like how did you what was the first
job that you got
when I was homeless yeah
uh I started because I grew up singing I
was like maybe I could get a gig
somewhere and start singing Because I
made money singing you know like for my
whole life since I was little like 100
bucks 200 bucks but whatever so I'd go
around to coffee shops um in the area
but San Diego started to be a hotbed for
signing activity you know grunge there
was a kind of a grunge scene in San
Diego
and so I'd go in there and they they
charged you to sing there I was like
this is not ideal like they wanted me to
pay them two hundred dollars I was like
yeah I was like this is the exact gig
yeah and it was the idea that you would
sell tickets they thought it was no they
thought it was like a signing you would
get signed oh God you know what I mean
because it became like so many record
labels I guess were coming down at the
time
I remember this one lady like my friend
let me sit in on his gig
so I go sing with him I'm starting to
write my own songs oh I forgot to tell
you how I started writing songs back at
school but I'll tell you later I
remember that so I started writing songs
um and singing my own stuff I get on my
friend's gig he's packed the place out I
don't clearly but he has a crowded
there's like a door charge so I go to
settle out while he's taking his gear
down and this woman coffee shop owner
was like you guys don't get the door
money I was like
what are you talking about like he
brought all these people in she's like
no she goes you get the tip jar and I
was like oh I was like you know what
then why don't we get all your coffee
and food money you could just give us
that instead
and she was like you don't get the food
beverage money you get the tip jar and I
was so upset I needed the money so badly
like I didn't have food you know like I
was
I was really wanting some money from
that gig and I remember I put my little
finger in her face and I was like I am
cursing you
whoa you are I know it sounded so heavy
I was like you are stealing from the
people that are giving you a living
you're stealing from this guy and I was
like you are you will go out of business
I was like nobody can stay in business
doing this to humans I was so upset at
her and I did he have a understanding
with her or was he I didn't care he just
didn't care I was so [ __ ] hippies
blown away I was like
he just wanted to be easy going and
didn't want to make her mad and wanted
to get another gig there and I was just
so upset and so I found this place I
liked this little when I was living in
my car there was a little tree that was
flowering tree and I like to park next
to it so like that was my home
and I noticed there was this coffee shop
right there that was going out of
business and it was really off the
beaten path
and so I went in there and I talked to
the lady who owned it her name was Nancy
and I was like do you think you could
stay open for two more months
she's like why I'm like if I bring
people in
can I keep the door money you can keep
all the coffee and food
and like we'll try and make it together
and she said yes and so I started going
down on like the beach front in San
Diego and I'd sing like Street sing
and I'd tell people I'm singing at the
interchange coffee shop on Thursday
night at six o'clock and
two people came like it was two Surfers
that thought I was hot I think
and I did a five hour show because bar
singing you do five hour shows and I
just thought I had to do a five hour
show so I started writing a ton of
material plus I was using writing not to
steal and I was a prolific Thief so I
had to become a prolific writer
and so I did this five hour show to
these two guys I'm bleeding my heart out
because I was so lonely and I realized I
never tell the truth like nobody knows
the truth I'm scared to death I'm not a
great person I'm stealing
and I'm lonely and I was like maybe if I
tell the truth I won't feel so lonely so
I made a promise that I would write
really honest songs so these poor two
servers were subjected to five hours of
like
bleeding out my like vocal cords
it was amazing I made ten dollars
and uh the next night then I would go
seeing all throughout Town Street Corner
I'd say hey Thursday night they knew
where to see me and it just grew it went
from two people to four people to eight
people
to 40 to 80 to capacity to people
standing outside watching me sing
through the window and I got discovered
yeah
it was nuts wow yeah that's a great
story
wow what was that like what was it what
was the feeling like when it was at
capacity and you recognize that these
people were that something was changing
in your life these people were coming
out to see you perform
coolest thing and why I'm smiling is
because I was changing it moves me to
tears right now
even before the people came I felt a
momentum shifting you know I just felt
I was getting better I was getting
healthier I was getting happier my panic
attacks like I found out how not to have
them
like it just made me feel good and then
when these people came
I just bore my soul and I just didn't
pull a punch and they
they liked me and I know this sounds
superficial but it wasn't because it was
so authentically me I wasn't pretending
to be better or more talented it was so
raw and people would cry and I would cry
and it was just such a real connection
like for the first time in my life I had
a real meaningful human connection and
it wasn't scary it felt good
and they would give me books to read and
they would give me food and I didn't
think it would lead to a record deal it
just felt like being fed for the first
time in your life you know not hiding
and not being fake and just being really
authentic so it felt really good and
then when more people came it just took
on a momentum that was like holy [ __ ]
how much time has passed from the two
people to people standing outside
I don't know but six months Maybe
ish something like that
that's a lot of change in six months
yeah maybe a little more eight months
but couldn't have been more than that
because I don't think I was homeless
more than a year what was that that
change how to feel crazy it was wild
it was cool and you know from like being
on stage but like I wouldn't make a set
list and I would just feel the audience
and like I talked I did a lot of I tell
a lot of stories and like kind of like
stand up I would just tell like just
stories and jokes and just shoot [ __ ]
with people in the audience and they
were just these really live electric
like kind of wild shows
and make them dead quiet and I would
just take a little break so people could
use the bathroom and
and when people started standing outside
and they couldn't hear but they were
just watching me through the window and
the look on their face like to this day
it like gives me chills like they looked
at me with like a certain look and it
was like holy [ __ ] like this is
different
and they would stand out in the rain
like we put little speakers out there so
they could hear and people would stand
in the rain and just listen to me
singing through the window with little
speakers and it was just like it was
very humbling like very very humbling
wow yeah
so then what happens how do you get
discovered
there was a
programmer
xic radio station
country they might have been number two
in the country at the time heavy
alternative station
uh somebody told them about this girl
singing in a coffee shop and that he
should come
and he came and I could recognize new
faces when they come in because it was
if this wasn't a big place by the way I
mean this might have been 70 people that
could fit inside that's a tiny costume
so you had developed a crowd like I
thought you were accustomed to seeing
familiar faces yeah it was a loyal
die-hard
Die Hard fan base like tiny don't get me
wrong but I knew them you know what I
mean it was it was like a little family
in a way and so this guy came in he had
a goatee slang shirt on he looked kind
of hard and he was sitting in the back
and I remember singing the song A
Thousand Miles Away and he was just
weeping like quietly but his tears were
streaming down his face
and he came up to me afterwards he's
like hey I'm at the radio station and
like why don't you come in like sing a
song one night or something and I was
like okay
so I go in there
still living in oh I got another car so
I had a car to live in I had saved up
enough door money to buy a car a cheap
car like a couple hundred little car
um so I get down to the radio station
and I sing a song for him and we talk a
little bit and um
I guess he went ahead him and this guy
named Lou Niles put it uh on the radio
and it got requested
um by fans it's back when you could
still request songs and they'd listen to
it and it got somehow into the top 20.
you know of this station which is a big
deal like top 20 on that station was
like you know labels pay a lot of money
to promote their artists to try and get
them into the top 20 and this was like
an acoustic guitar demo
in the middle of like all this Grunge
music and so record labels really
how that what is this song that's
showing up on this playlist and they
would call him and he's like it's this
chick down at this coffee shop and so
all of a sudden there would be like
these limousines pulling up
and they would give sweet little Nancy
you know that was just she was having a
banging business now which Felt So Good
and they would be like she'd be like
Jewel Sony records here tonight I'd be
like all right I was so passe about the
whole thing it was very funny
um and then they'd take me out to tacos
and
talk to me about record deals and and
then there was a bidding war it was
every label came down every label
they've flown from New York they bring
in bigger Executives than they'd fly in
they'd come again they'd you know all
these limousines showing up
and I would start to got flown around to
talk to different record labels and how
did this process take I don't know
I am I'm kind of bad with time that way
I don't know a couple months something
like that and you don't have a manager
you don't have anybody speaking for you
no but I went to the library and I found
this book called
[Laughter]
yourself Fight For Dummies
it was Don passenheim I think called
everything you need to know about the
music business oh boy and that sounded
good so I read it and I just learned
about Mechanicals and royalties and
back-ends and advances oh so you did
your homework I did my homework and
there ended up being a huge bidding war
over me all the labels just started like
competing by this time I kind of found
like a de facto manager
um I maybe got a lawyer here at some
point you know and this might now have
taken more time
but I realized because of reading that
book that an advances alone you don't
get to keep the money
you pay it back through record sales
and so I did the math to see how many
records I'd have to sell to pay back a
million dollars and it was a lot of
Records
and so it was like having a bounty on my
head as an artist I almost didn't sign
my record deal because I had just
figured out how to be happy like
genuinely I was really starting to
figure it out and I knew it like inside
myself I was doing so much better
and God forbid you take somebody with my
emotional background and they ever get
famous I'm the recipe for every movie
you've seen about every musician like
right
and again I didn't want to be a
statistic and I fought so hard for my
happiness up to this point that I was
like I don't think I could trust myself
to have a record deal
and figure out how to do that career
without self-employing so I almost
didn't sign it
I remember being on the beach one day
and I was like
I wanted to do it but I was terrified of
doing it so I made myself a promise that
my number one job would still be to
figure out how to be happy and my number
two job would be to be a musician
and then under the musician category
that I wanted to be an artist more than
I wanted to be famous
and so knowing those was like having my
North Star and I felt like I could
navigate and make decisions based on
those things
and so I went ahead and signed the
record deal I turned down the advance I
turned down a million dollar bonus holy
[ __ ] as a homeless kid oh my God
oh my God that is so crazy and I took
the biggest do that that's I would have
taken that money for sure a hundred
percent I don't know I'll figure it out
in the future taking this money I'm
getting a [ __ ] fat apartment
overlooking the water
this is not what I did as a homeless kid
you'd pass on a million bucks I did wow
but I took the biggest back end anybody
had ever been awarded and so if I sold
records I was going to make a [ __ ] ton
so because like under the artist
category I wanted to be an artist more
than I wanted to be famous and it meant
I had to put myself in an environment
and in a position to win as a
singer-songwriter and as a folk singer
no less at the height of grunge the odds
of that working I knew were really Slim
and I felt like the bidding war over me
was just much more of like a dick
contest between all the labels I didn't
think it necessarily had to do with my
talent I thought it was talented but I
thought the odds were still really
really against me
and I had to put myself in a position to
be able to
weather the fact that my first album may
not be successful
but if you have a million dollar signing
bonus you have to have your first let
record be successful or else you'll get
dropped because you cost so much the
label and so I was just doing it to put
myself in a position to make my art
first and to not leverage my art unduly
you know it's like saying you have to
grow a pair but you don't even have a
tree yet like I had to grow a tree like
the pear was a long way away and so I
just tried to look at it kind of
agriculturally or in a natural system of
like I have to grow I have to plant a
seed I have to like grow a tree you know
watch the entire episode for free only
on Spotify